that's right folks thirty years ago
today depending on the time zone you
live in Back to the Future hit theaters
so I figure this is a pretty good
opportunity to review it because if not
now when
really what no one was reviewed on the
31st anniversary come on
back to the future I'm gonna have some
spoilers I can talk about everything in
the movie they're definitely spoilers so
back to the feature is one of my
favorite childhood memory movies of all
time
it's up there man I watched this movie
all the time and in Back to the Future
Marty McFly played by Michael J Fox he
has hopes he has dreams he's in high
school he's kind of down on his luck his
family situation isn't the most
optimistic thing to go home to so dr. M
and L Brown played by Christopher Lloyd
calls him to meet him in the mall
parking lot at like 1:00 or 2:00 a.m. to
show him his new project God knows why
those high school students hanging out
with this old scientist and why this old
scientist is hanging out with this high
school student it never explains that
was normal in the eighties folks I guess
but he has built a time machine out of a
car called a DeLorean
so then these Libyans attacks they shoot
up the doc Marty gets into the DeLorean
he just guns it it hits 88 miles an hour
boom goes right back to 1955 he's stuck
in 1955 he needs to get back to 1985 but
there's no more plutonium he can't get
the 1.21 gigawatts of electricity he
needs so he goes to young doc still
played by Christopher Lloyd for help and
Marty has a flyer saying and the
anniversary at the clock tower that was
struck by lightning conveniently in 1955
so basically Marty's gonna have to get
the electricity from the clock tower
into the DeLorean right when he hits 88
miles an hour and he can go home all the
while he meets his young parents who
just Crispin Glover plays his young dad
and Crispin Glover is one of the
weirdest human beings that ever took up
acting one of probably not the weirdest
weirdest I can think if he tried to kick
David Letterman in the head we don't
know that clip YouTube it it's out there
and the problem is Marty accidentally
intervened in what would have been his
parents meeting now his mom met him his
mom has a crush on him it's that weird
Oh would be if I were him so time's
blinking Marty's family out of existence
so Marty just has to fix it and get back
home all the while dodging Biff who's
the biggest douchebag ever in movies one
up there's something about the high
school bully it's worse than any
supervillain worse than anyone with
superpowers the bully man and the Biff
yeah bullet
first it's great to see Marty standing
up to Biff he's just one of those
liberating things you're like yeah Marty
talk punch him do the thing I love
a lot about Back to the Future is just
from the get-go it's perfect for
families I'll tell you why because when
doc is explaining to Marty how time
works he demonstrates it with his dog
and you get it I mean I was like five
when I first saw Back to the Future and
I totally got it all so yeah I get how
time travel works I guess it doesn't go
into the science of it it just kind of
illustrates how it works and it's just
anybody who's anybody will understand it
and honestly Michael J Fox and
Christopher Lloyd's chemistry in this
movie just like Harrison Ford and Sean
Connery's and Indiana Jones in the Last
Crusade just the best out there actually
features is one of those movies I look
at I feel old when I say it but I
actually say to myself and like they
don't make them like this anymore it is
the quintessential family fun adventure
that's good for all ages not just kids
not just adults anyone can watch it
relate to it and love it and the end of
this movie my God when he has to hit the
gas and the DeLorean breaks Doc's
working up there at the clock tower
trying to get the wires oh my god is
happening on the lightnings gonna strike
the most intense you've ever seen
and that song kicks on when he guns is
just and land and under Dayton did not
die don't die I love that theme it's
just one of the best ever made I've
watched that end clip on YouTube a
hundred times I watched the movie more
than that I mean if I'm thinking of
negatives in this movie I can't think of
any the one thing that's kind of out of
place is after everything is fixed
George McFly Dex Biff all's right with
the world and that one dude who looks
like Sherman aiders like beat it McFly
starts dancing with Lorraine and he's
off I'm like that that's just kind of
out of nowhere and George McFly just
kind of pushes into the ground it's like
excuse me oh my god that was there and
over you can argue the movies trying to
illustrate constants and variables I
feel like it's just kind of an out of
place sane to give you one last moment
of tension before the big moment of
tension when Marty might not get back
home and that is another thing when
Doc's like alright there's an alarm
clock on the dashboard when that rings
you hit the gas and the alarm clock
rings Marty tries to hit the gas the car
dies for like a minute I feel like with
Doc Brown being so precise in his
calculations that minute lost means he's
not going back home he wouldn't have
made it in time oh well we roll with it
because it's an awesome nostalgic movie
nostalgia is like love it's so powerful
you look past that icing on the
cake Marty gets back and his life is
what
wonderful now because everything that
happened when he was there made a domino
effect where his life is now just gold
his parents have good jobs they're happy
they're not frumpy anymore George McFly
doesn't laugh like the best of which is
the lesson that just stand up to a bully
don't let people push you around all
your life George McFly Dex Biff now Biff
is waxing cars not this is a bad job for
people who wax cars it's just a few
steps up from doing bifs homework and
then doing Biff's work work for him as
you're an adult he's still pushing you
around just holding his balls over your
head we're like let's stop Biff stop
guys in the end Back to the Future is
one of the quintessential adventure
movies ever made I don't know whether or
not it's an adventure a comedy a sci-fi
all of a but it's all the above they
truly don't make them like this anymore
I may sound like an old saying that
but that's just the truth they don't
this movie is timeless I have watched it
all my life I will continue to watch it
all my life because Back to the Future
is awesome tacular all right guys still
back to the future have you seen it what
did you think about it but every thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you